[Music]
oops she did it again
Britney Spears is sharing her latest
injury to social media and showing fans
exactly how she accidentally broke a
bone in her foot while dancing she
posted this video since the gram with
the caption quote I haven't danced in
six months so I was full throttle at
this spot and yes I know I'm barefoot
don't laugh but I grip the floor better
that way
PS you can hear where I broke my foot
here sorry it's kind of loud it's been
just a little over a week since
Brittany's boyfriend Sam s Gauri shared
that the singer had an incident on
Instagram he posted this photo with the
caption quote when you break something
it tends to heal stronger especially
when your my girl
[Music]
the 38 year old singer is no stranger to
dance related injuries having hurt her
knee in both 1999 and 2004 and in 2015
she visited Ellen after rolling her
ankle on stage what happened well I
actually wasn't doing anything that hard
I was just kind of bopping around and
I've done like eight years worth the
show whoo plenty of shows and I never
actually fell on stage so I really kind
of embarrassing but I just yeah I fell
down and then I got up and I my dancers
kind of guided me to keep going
last night Brittany took a moment on
Instagram to show her appreciation some
members of the Brittany army who visited
the zone
the ultimate Britney fan interactive
experience in Los Angeles I couldn't
make it to the zone unfortunately I've
been dancing and I broke my foot
but you guys sent me these really cool
letters and you put them out in my
locker and I'm so excited to share them
with you do miss Brittany we confess
we're so lucky to be here at the zone
sometimes life is like a crazy circus
but every time we think of you we feel
stronger and less crazy in this toxic
toxic world we love you till the world
ends work [ __ ] Kelly and Chris thank
you guys he got the chance to go inside
and journey through the nine interactive
rooms that are replicas of the pop stars
most iconic videos we also chatted with
the brains behind the ultimate Britney
fan experience to see how all of this
came to be whose idea was it it was
yours you're wearing the Britney Spears
t-shirt we're a group of fans we love
Britney Spears and we're also big fans
of immersive experiences and we got to
be amazing to create the ultimate
experience for Britney so um how how
involved was Britney in this whole thing
Britney definitely is a big supporter
and she's very passionate about this and
you know she likes experiences so you
know very big fan and we as a group
designed you know everything and really
put like our heart and passion into it
it's not Brittany's place this is your
place and she's putting on her Instagram
to her millions and millions and
millions and millions of fans like go
see this but she doesn't have like she's
not an investor
her team is like how's that work so it's
fan generated but we had Britney's
blasting was important to us that she
was a part of it so she's super
supportive and really passionate about
it and she wanted to make sure that her
fans had access to this experience
[Music]